eh bien vous l'attendiez cette vidéo et
puis moi aussi bizarrement ça y est le
nouveau trailer de star wars 8 est enfin
sorti et du cou et du coup je me suis
dit un petit facetime reaction ça
pourrait être sympa pour la sortie de du
trailer de l'opus suite justement alors
je vous préviens tout de suite je vais
très spontané jeu peut-être pas dire des
choses forcément excellente mais c'est
surtout réagir au trailer voir comment
il est
et puis voilà par contre je garantis pas
d'émettre vraiment des grosses théorie
je sais pas si un trop théorie sortira à
la suite de ce trailer on verra mais
c'est pas sûr on verra enfin bref
allons-y donc je lance
le trailer alors attention quand je t'ai
trouvée j'ai décelé en toi une puissance
brute est intenté et au delà de ça autre
chose de tout à fait exceptionnel
[Musique]
quelque chose
ce meilleur mois depuis toujours
[Musique]
cest et février
et je vous en tête
[Musique]
je m' avait senti une telle énergie à
l'état brut qu'une seule fois je n'en
avais pas eu assez peur alors
[Musique]
aujourd'hui mes frais
laisse mourir le passé
tulle
s'il le faut
c'est la seule façon de devenir ce que
tu dois être
[Musique]
nous sommes l'étincelle
qui allumera l'incendié
qui réduira le premier ordre
ça ne se passera pas
[Musique]
tu crois
il est temps
on peut lire
j'ai besoin que quelqu'un le dise où est
ma place dans tout ça
[Musique]
waouh je sais pas trop quoi dire là y'a
tellement de choses il ya tellement
d'informations c'est incroyable déjà ce
qui est très bien donc c'est je suis
content c'est que cas il aurait au final
c'est fin c'est comme on va dire
l'identique de ré ces genres l'opposé de
ré au final calais lorraine est un va
peut-être sûrement devenir un réel
personnage principal par rapport à ray
est il justement il prend encore
beaucoup plus de puissance par rapport
au premier film c'est exactement ça j'en
étais sûr c'est ce que j'attendais et
j'en suis très content après est-ce qui
retournera sa veste dans l'opus neuf ça
on verra plus tard c'est c'est vraiment
c'est loin encore et on n'en est pas là
du tout mais quelle lorraine va avoir
beaucoup plus de puissance sky lorraine
sera aura un rôle très important et il
pourrait même tuer les ja et je pense
qu'il va tuer luke
car on le remarque un moment lucas
moment se met à gueuler un petit peu
tout seul il y a une voix à terre sous
la pluie il dit ça ne se passera pas
comme ça et je pense que c'est là où
l'udc va mourir face à kei lorraine je
suis sûr à 100% que l'udc va mourir de
la main de kay lorraine sûrement et
ouais je pense ce sera de la main de
kayes lorraine et voilà donc après il ya
tellement d'informations donc fine
revient ça ça va être cool fine
toutefois son film c'était évident qu'il
allait revenir mais là il a l'air de
prendre un bon rôle
les y'a bon elle va pas disparaître je
pense pas les ya normalement il
disparaît pas après c'est un petit spoil
pas voulu mais normalement les ja et les
sens et [ __ ] il ya des abonnements
voilà j'ai retiré c'est quand il ya des
live via les abonnements cetera bref
du coup les ya normalement va pas mourir
du coup mais qu'at il aurait n'hésite
franchement et ça prouve quelque chose
s'écaille lorraine à une faiblesse quand
même par rapport à l'eia et je pense
qu'il pourrait certainement retourner sa
veste en faveur du côté lumineux mais
bon ça c'est pareil c'est pas la
question va pas s'installer là dessus on
voit snow que ça fait plaisir de voir ce
n'est qu'au départ je crois que c'était
yoda qui parlait j'ai eu un petit [ __ ]
c'est yoda et non non non c'est pas yoda
alors du coup reste c'est pareil donc
réel en train de se chercher
rae du coup va faire l'enseignement avec
lui qui a des passages là quand on la
voit elle est sur une planète un peu je
crois que c'est la même planète que dans
le cinq camps
lucas prend avec yoda c'est exactement
penser à ça c'est jean rey va apprendre
avec l'udc
ça peut être vraiment bien cependant
réelle se cherche et je pense que l'udc
va pas être très tendres ce qui va pas
vouloir enseigner quelque chose à la
base justement ça les ferait donc
justement il a rencontré qu'une personne
n'a qu'un pouvoir brut comme ça donc
caille lawrence est évident c'est kyle
lorraine donc c'est un petit peu les
opposer en fait c'est les identique est
l'opposé pense à je pense à j'arrête pas
de penser à la fin du trailer parce que
la fin du trailer elle est quand même
assez impressionnante quand
qu'il aurait le temps la main un rêve
parce qu'elle cherche le chemin auquel
allaient hec pas franchement je suis là
je suis paumé là dessus je suis sûr que
ray maîtrisera les deux côtés de la
force cependant je pense pas qu'elle va
rejoindre calais lorraine
surtout suite au décès de ian solo
je pense qu'il va il va s'installer
entre les deux personnages un lien cette
révision peut-être déjà un lien de
parenté quelque chose mais je pense que
les deux personnages vont avoir un lien
qui vont s'imposer entre eux dans ce
très dans le prochain film mais je pense
vraiment pas que rêve à agencer rien du
tout je pense pas je pense pas ça serait
pas ça serait pas disney ça serait pas
star wars ray je pense pas qu'elle va
rejoindre calais lorraine dans le côté
obscur mais ils vont bien tenter de la
faire rejoindre elle va ré affronter
calais lorraine ça c'est sûr snob va
aussi tenter de dallas convertir mais je
ne pense pas je ne pense pas du tout en
tout cas le premier renvoie faire de
gros dégâts je pense que c'est le
premier ordre qui va dominer sur ce
huitième film c'est c'est sûr à 100% et
ça va envoyer du loing là le trailer il
envoie du lourd
après c'est un trailer il faut pas trop
sortir des choses de son contexte
il met des petits bouts donc on pense
facilement à des choses alors qu'au
final ça c'est pas du tout avec la même
chose dans le film mais il va y avoir
beaucoup d'action ça va être bien ça va
être vraiment bien sa grand mère je suis
là j'ai eu des frissons la gta ip ça va
être cool
que dire d'autre que dire d'autre on
voit plein de choses le capitaine alors
le capitaine comment il s'appelle déjà
face mahou place match c'est plus du
coup a survécu pourtant ils l'ont mis
dans la benne à ordure mais bon en même
temps c'est évident qu'à l'est pas
mourir comme une heure comme ça la
petite brienne de torses 1 pour ceux qui
reconnaîtront et donc elle va survivre
ça va être l'opposé de je pense de fine
fine va du coup s bat se bat avec elle
puis voilà quoi dire de plus
je sais vraiment pas si 1,3 théorie
s'enchaînera suite à cette vidéo sur le
trailer de star wars 8
n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires évidemment n'hésitez
vraiment pas à me le dire mais j'en sais
rien 1/3 théorie basée sur un trailer
bon je sais pas trop quoi surtout qu'on
a déjà beaucoup parlé star wars mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya matière à dire et
il va se passer beaucoup de choses l'ubs
va enseigner ouèrè mais je pense qu'il
va mourir franchement je change pas trop
sur mes positions qui lorraine va avoir
un rôle important reda c'est le rôle
décisif
elle va être ans elle va apprendre la
force vue grâce à luc ludlum mourir pour
moi bah les gars va survivre film va
survivre peau alors peau d'âme rhône
j'en sais rien du tout s'il va mourir
mais va se passer les choses aussi avec
lui du coup chez oui c'est toi un
nouveau petit copain ça fait un peu jeu
s'appelle route
ça me fait penser à ça je peux pourquoi
le gardien la galaxie avoir juste pour
terminer avait écailles lorraine sont
identiques franchement ils ont le même
pouvoir ils ont franchement ils ont la
même d'avoir le même taux 2010 clôt rien
quelque chose comme ça qui doit être
supérieure à lui qu on aime tant lui que
c'est pas c'est pas les lui c'est pas
comme anakin mais il ya quelque chose
après tout c'est un skywalker caille
lorraine rsa force vient forcément
quelque chose à part si c'est une élue
un petit peu comme darth plagueis mais
du coup cela voudrait dire que ce ne
pourrait être d'arc l'église du coup
admettons admettons c'est la meilleure
théorie sur stock mes rêves je veux bien
qu'à lever des parents qui viennent de
nulle part mais l off
il ya forcément quelque chose pour moi
qui fait qu'elles aient un pouvoir aussi
surhumain en fait exactement comme cai
lorraine alors que kyle au rsa justifie
il est le petit fils de l'élu saint
skywalker
il baigne dedans depuis qu'il est tout
petit la force réelle découvre ses
pouvoirs
elle a la même force ça sommeille en
elle il ya forcément quelque chose un
lien il ya quelque chose je n'affirme
rien je ne dis pas que res voir la fille
de l'ue coach je fais attention à ça
mais rey a forcément ça vient pas de
nulle part cette force et franchement
pensez-y je pense que on va en apprendre
des choses sur la famille de ré et
et on sera sûrement étonner ou surpris
enfin ça sera vraiment cool ça se trouve
ce qui va y avoir du nouveau personnage
un petit peu considérés comme des élus
qui vont être créés ça va être leurs
descendantes ou vont s'inspirer
peut-être de l'univers étendu de
certaines choses
après ça je peux pas trop rentrer là
dedans moi c'est surtout les films
enfin voila je vois vraiment pas quoi
dire de plus à part que j'ai des
frissons je suis vraiment épais j'espère
que ces petites vidéos vous aura plu en
tout cas les amis n'hésitez pas à me
dire dans les commentaires si vous
voulez trois théories sur à propos de ce
trailer mais je ne sais pas trop a vous
de me dire avoir vos réactions tout ça
et je réfléchirai de mon côté aussi
et puis bah écoute et j'espère que cette
vidéo vous aura plu c'était un argot
rock que le liner soit avec vous
vivement star wars 8
et voilà je vous fais des gros bisous
[Musique]